yeah I do because it's not it's not a
selfless thing it makes me feel like I'm
useful yeah Jenna's no therapy dog yeah
here's another thing that I'll here's
what I like about you though is you're
very reliable you're reliable you've
helped us out in a jam so many [ __ ]
times I can't even name the amount of
times I mean you're always there for us
you're know usually I mean I hate giving
people compliments but it hurts me to do
it you've really you yeah yeah but
everything's bleeding discharged you
know you have really helped us out in a
pinch and there are things that you do
and I honestly like um you are an enigma
to me because I honestly believe that
what the [ __ ] why aren't you could you
can act you're great actress you know
what is it gonna take for you to get
something she should have stuck with
stand-up and she didn't remember she
didn't you get spots with you yeah or
even sketch maybe even a little bit yeah
I mean I love I loved when I did
stand-up except I I saw in my mind that
it was a whole other career and I was
like I just got to stick with acting and
take acting classes and try and get a
manager and try and get I don't really
know what it's gonna take guys to be
honest it's tough it is very tough yeah
but a lot of it has to do with just
being in the pocket still yeah you know
I was I've said this before I don't know
if I've said this recently but I saw
that Joan Rivers documentary about
standing out in the rain you know you
just have to stand out in the rain
you're gonna get struck by lightning and
or there's another analogy about waves
you know what you just you're out there
in the ocean
sometimes you'll hit a big wave you'll
ride it for a long time but sometimes
it's dead and the way it's not there you
just have to stay out there you know and
the waves are long sometimes are short
but just have fun being out in the water
yeah I don't feel like I'm anywhere near
drowning or feeling like I want to go
back to shore
and pick something else to do yeah I
just understand that there's a lot that
I don't understand I don't know how it's
gonna happen yeah that I'm here but you
also haven't had anything devastating
happen either in the industry yeah a lot
of times devastation happens where it's
like I mean here's a prime example
chicken you knew chicken is years ago
there was a guy named chicken and he
went to the Montreal Comedy Festival he
got like a half a million dollar deal at
Warner Brothers and then he had his own
sketch show called hype and Frank
Caliendo was on it a lot of people that
Danielle Gaither was on it Shaima Tosh
my old roommate was on it it was a
sketch on the Warner Brothers and then
he also got that movie X or xxx right
where you played the scientist and then
years went by you haven't heard from him
because those things just faded abruptly
which he could probably consider as
being devastating because it is
devastating not to be on top and enough
fall you know and then they found his
dead body in an apartment in like North
Carolina or something yeah I think I
haven't had anything devastating happen
in that sense because I haven't had
anything to lose like if you have a
million million dollars and you lose it
you're gonna be devastated versus if you
had a penny and you're like oh it fell
through the hole but a lot of times
though but a high but a lot of times
right it's you'd rather not get that
like for instance I'm gonna name a name
Carlos Mencia I love him by-the-bye yeah
I really do by the by I love him okay
but Mencia was on top of the world his
own show this and that and then if the
world just came crashing down on him
right he still makes a great living but
he you know it's almost as if like for
me I never really kind of made it but I
always kind of got jobs so I could the
dream kept stay
alive I never got too big you know me I
would get like a job here and there it
would fade out stay in the pocket and
then I would get another job it could
happen for me but in many ways I'm so
glad I didn't hit big and then fall deep
a lot of times hitting big and falling
deep is painful it happened to Pauly
Shore I saw Pauly rise to the top and
then him being the butt of jokes and he
had to live through that I don't know if
I could do that you would destroy me it
seems like it's way harder to recover
from that you still have hope you still
have a dream yeah you know and that you
should hang on to that also because
high-rises and fast Falls I don't know
how to do I also know another girl who
I'm not gonna name her name she was she
did a pilot right she was struggling for
years she did a pilot and he got picked
up in the week before the show get
started filming they replaced her but it
was sex in the city and she would have
to drive by The Sex in the City
billboards and then she just left wait
how do you ever get over that
now Sex and the City is there still it
still happens all the time when people
just kind of get fired and then the next
thing or that girl from Game of Thrones
who had was Khaleesi they didn't
Thailand yes replaced her yeah I think
the funniest thing that Jenna or it
probably wasn't as devastating but the
way I recall it is um we were supposed
to go to Dodger game together and you
and then you weren't able to because you
booked the job and you're like well
what's the job and you're like oh it's a
commercial and I go what are you what do
you play she's like I'm like I'm a
molecule what do you mean you're a
molecule she's like yeah I think like an
actual like hydrogen atom yeah I was I
was a hydrogen what they had you in a
hydrogen atom
it was just your face floating around
the screen yeah and then when I got to
set cuz the hydrogen atom was like the
one that they were gonna be playing and
all the gas stations on TV yeah lots of
money lots of money I mean it still paid
my rent for like a year but I got there
and they're like oh you no longer have
17 lines we're putting you in a baseball
outfit and I was like what about the
atoms and you know the I mean the
process to book that job
we don't same because there were 17
lines and they just had people going in
and out and in and out and they wanted
you to be funny when you were talking
about science so you got fired as a
hydrogen atom and they put you in a
baseball out and then they were like oh
and you're not saying anything
another one I'm there all day it was
with this remember when I was at the
Rose Bowl they rented out the Rose yeah
yeah so this was a national commercial
that I would still be making money her
bomb right yeah so they they had
originally hired me as a girlfriend and
then on the day they were like so you're
gonna be this little boy's mom and
here's your husband
I didn't look old enough but we did a
rehearsal at the Rose Bowl and were the
last shot of the day they've got the
whole stadium for my part the director
comes out of village
and he's like yeah can we just get the
mom out of there oh my god the [ __ ] and
he he and no one told me anything they
didn't tell me if they were gonna keep
shooting if they were gonna use me for
something else they just had me sitting
there like yeah just can you just move
out of there for a second so I just
stood there now what are you thinking at
this point I'm thinking I really need
this money yeah are they gonna at least
pay me
this is so brutal and the thing is is
that I knew I told my mom I was like
there's no way that I can be this kid's
mom I don't look old enough yeah
there's no way that this is gonna work
and it's like one day I get auditions
for the head of the FBI know I be the
CEO of like Pepsi yeah do you read no
that's right anyway so you're sitting
there you're like I'm too young for this
no one's paying attention to me there oh
my god rolling cuz they're like we're
gonna lose light and they've rented out
the entire Rose Bowl they've got
hundreds of extras I mean it was a
production this director had also
directed some of them Beyonce's what was
that album lemonade yeah so great
director and I'm just sitting there like
hey so does anyone uh I call my agent
I'm like hey just to give you a heads up
I don't know what the [ __ ] is going on
but they just told me to clear frame and
I'm like at the same time I'm like I
know this [ __ ] happens but I really need
the money and it was a huge national and
then afterwards I went up to the
director cuz I'm like hey so no one's
let me know you know what's what's going
on are we he didn't explain anything and
then he rapped everyone and I was like
okay so you're not using me and then he
was like hey I just want to let you know
you were great
you're beautiful I'm like this has
nothing to do with anything
Wow piece of [ __ ] [ __ ] rat [ __ ] and
he's like I mean you're gorgeous you
were oh [ __ ] you I want my money
yeah he's like but you could clearly
don't look old enough to be this boy's
mom and I was like I know you know like
yeah not only did we have an audition
and a callback but then after that they
had another day at the fitting where
they took us all into the clients to
show who we were
yeah but it's a it no you know what dude
at that point I complain you say is it
what I say something I go listen listen
I'm not an extra I auditioned I got the
part this is not professional it's not
you know you you you
you do this process beforehand I know K
I can get let go at a table read I can
get let go some sort of screen test or
rehearsal right but not on game day
[ __ ] yeah okay
that's [ __ ] unprofessional right
there man yeah and then yeah you know
what I want you to do I'm like go on top
of that you gonna tell me the director's
name and later a production company and
production company I'm gonna [ __ ]
pert burn them on fire so much money
what I mean they have so I don't give a
[ __ ] that's unprofessional [ __ ] what
was the what was the product do you
remember oh you're trying to save face
huh no I don't remember it was um
Frank's hot dogs Frank's hot dogs
at the Rose Bowl and it was with an NFL
player oh maybe it was for the NFL but
and a [ __ ] you NFL hole lead it's
billions of dollars make something out
it [ __ ] it man [ __ ] you in a fancy Pepsi
OH
bastards Cola actually I don't [ __ ] with
Coca Cola so let's just say it was
[Music]